[Musique]
bonjour comment parler de quelque chose
que j'aime et comment le faire
si ce quelque chose ce sont les
mathématiques des nombres premiers
leur répartition des fractales qu'ils
grandissent comme des branches d'arbres
des courbes qui remplissent le plan des
jo des ics sur la surface d'un
ellipsoïde d'épaulé à dreux régulier en
grande dimension des pavages qui
ressemble le réseau de cristaux des
chorégraphies mathématiques détresse
mathématiques des noeuds mathématiques
du chaos mathématiques tout ça j'ai
décidé de ne pas en parler
je m'excuse auprès de ceux et celles qui
sont maintenant intéressé mais je ne
vais pas vous faire un cours de
mathématiques je vous ne ferai pas de
cours de mathématiques
même si j'aime beaucoup faire cela mais
j'ai appris à reconnaître que dans
chaque salle il ya des personnes qui
n'ont pas envie en cours de
mathématiques j'ai envie de vous parler
de comment je vois les mathématiques
maintenant bien sûr ce ne sont que des
opinions et des ressentis personnel des
images qui me viennent quand je pense
aux mathématiques mais j'ai envie de
penser que dans ma perception
il ya quelque chose qui leur est propre
quelque chose qui ne provient pas de ma
perception mais qui influencent le taux
cette perception
quelque chose de purement mathématique
ça fait 15 ans que je fais de maths
d'abord en russie en tant qu'école hier
et puis en france en tant que tu es hard
et ça fait trois ans qu'ils se montrent
travail ça fait trois ans que je suis
payé pour ça ça ne fait que trois ans
que je suis chercheuse en mathématiques
donc je ne peux pas prétendre dit tout
connaître
mais j'ai très envie de vous parler de
mathématiques parce que moi j'existe en
partie soyons honnêtes
j'existe à travers lui mathématiques et
ses mathématiques ils m'ont changé et
j'en ai beaucoup appris et surtout j'ai
envie d'en parler parce que je rencontre
souvent des personnes qui me parle de
mathématiques et à travers leurs mots et
leurs récents team décrivent les
mathématiques
leur mathématiques dans lesquels et son
nul dans les télés sont pas bons dans
lesquels ils se sentent forcer à
réfléchir et je vois au monde de
mathématiques différents presqu'un
pentagone east à celui que j'ai appris à
connaître
je me questionne quelles peuvent être
les raisons dans l'absence d'intérêt aux
mathématiques
je me demande aussi quelle est ma
responsabilité en tant que chercheuse et
en tant que vous le dire ça tu ris dans
cette absence d'intérêt
est-ce que moi même avec ma propre
discours passionné en diplôme à la main
je crée un sentiment chez vous que les
mathématiques ne peuvent être
accessibles qu'aux chercheurs
universitaires
d'où vient la peur des mathématiques et
d'où viennent les violences que nous
subissons et que nous créons et dont les
mots thématique sert de moyen et c'est
quoi les vrais mathématiques sont elles
violentes sont et le gentil où c'est à
nous de définir comment les approprier
je propose que ne regardions tous
ensemble et chacun pour soi dans la
direction mathématiques
qu'est ce qu'elle nous pouvons aussi
voir quelle émotion quelle question
quelle compréhension et quelle
découverte
j'ai envie de penser que si je passe
assez de temps à faire des mathématiques
je peux vraiment apprendre à les
connaître à ma façon
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup les
longs voyages en train le siège de
confortables je peux toujours reposer
mon regard par la fenêtre en couloir est
là pour marcher ceci est une
configuration idéale pour faire un peu
de mathématiques je vous remontre cahier
g/km question qui me guidera pour ce
voyage je dessine le petit figure je
regarde comment les choses évoluent cas
par cas je réfléchis je m'habitue aux
problèmes qui m'intéresse parfois je me
distrait et je dessine des petits
bonhommes mais la plupart du temps la
question qui m'intéresse ne va pas être
résolue dans un seul voyage
mathématiquement je ne veux rien
comprendre
la question qui m'intéresse va rester et
clips dans mon
on y est entouré par les images le
formulent les petits bonhommes
visuellement ça fait un joli page
mais mathématiquement ça reste un échec
la question mathématique ne peut pas
être résolue dans un seul voyage même
entre rennes et lyon ne pas comprendre
m'arrive bien bien plus souvent que de
comprendre une dizaine de voyages ne
suffisent pas
l'état dans lequel je me retrouve quand
je fais des mathématiques c'est l'état
de l'incompréhension permanente une
sorte de tempête dans la mer dans
laquelle je m'accroche chose que je
connais mon bateau en essayant de
naviguer une tempête à laquelle on
s'habitue
c'est ça les maths pour moi une tempête
dans laquelle parfois le soleil nous
faire un clin d'oeil à travers les
nuages
ces moments de soleil ce sont les
moments de compréhension ou plutôt de
l'anticipation de compréhension le
sentiment que là je vais peut-être
pouvoir comprendre que la mer va se
calmer pour un petit moment et que je
vais pour pouvoir passer
c'est ça une tempête dans la mer avec
des petits moments d'espoir comment je
peux y retrouver de l'assurance et du
plaisir je pense un renforcement bateau
est aussi un apprenant par où passent
les courants dans cette mer infinie
j'ai appris que pour avancer vraiment
mathématiques
je suis obligé de ne pas forcer mon
bateau à aller dans une direction
or rien dans le paysage ne m'amène de ne
pas me désespère et si je ne comprends
pas et surtout si je ne comprends rien
du tout de me satisfaire du fait que je
comprends mieux ce que je ne comprends
pas de décrire de façon la plus claire
ce qui n'est pas clair de décrire ou
plus précisément l'état de mon propre
désarroi les mathématiques m'habitue à
l'échec quasi permanent mais ce n'est
pas avoir réussi à mathématiques qui
renforce le bateau c'est d'avoir échoué
à ces deux fois pour avoir compris
quelque chose je ne pense pas que les
mathématiques sont une exception ici
pour apprendre à marcher chaque bébé
va devoir tomber beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de fois les enfants ont l'air
d'accepter la chute avec tant de
simplicité
il se relève et leur marche il continue
à explorer mais accepter la chute est
nécessaire pour avancer
c'est pour ça que je pense que tous les
enfants sont par définition des
baumettes
ils sont curieux et n'ont peur de rien
c'est eux qui doivent être nos
professeurs grâce aux mathématiques et à
leur immensité
je me rends compte à quel point je suis
petit dans le paysage global
il ya de la jabra lyneel les nerfs la
géométrie algébrique de la théorie de
nombre des systèmes dynamiques de la
théorie de probabilités de l'analyse
complexe de l'analyse fonctionnelle
je ne vais jamais tout apprendre à
mathématiques je ne vais jamais tout
comprendre
il y aura toujours des questions
ouvertes en mathématiques les
mathématiques sont grandes
ils sont infinies la mer est sombre et
mon bateau depuis ti mais parlons de ce
bateau il est quand même bien fait ce
bâton il n'est pas qu'un mois c'est un
bateau de connaissances c'est un bateau
qui est construit avec des idées entre
les planches et les cirés renforcée par
la logique mathématique c'est l'appareil
mathématiques et la curiosité qui le
porte et qui le nourrissent et ce bateau
nous le construisons ensemble défi des
siècles chaque réflexion renforce ce
bateau les nouveaux thèmes sont basés
sur les anciens il ne va jamais coulé ce
bateau il cache beaucoup de belles
histoires
c'est un bateau de connaissances dans la
mer de l'inconnu
c'est un bateau qui est né dans la mer
qu'ils parcourent en bateau en train à
pied ou n'importe comment
ce que je sais sûrement c'est que les
distances sont grandes en mathématiques
en aller retour entre antibes et riant à
un hymne et henri manil berthe damart et
tout un tas de mathématiciens
mathématicienne aujourd'hui
d'aujourd'hui peut ne pas suffire de
prouver une seule conjectures des
distances en mathématiques se mesure par
des centaines de kilomètres parcourus
par des centaines de personnes les
mathématiques du monde du temps faut du
temps pour comprendre
faut aussi du temps à soi je fréquente
beaucoup de mathématiciens et je vois de
mieux en mieux qu' il n'y a pas de façon
universelle à faire des mathématiques
les mathématiques sont en langage
universel certes c'est un outil
universel mais c'est aussi personnel
profond de man est évidemment personnel
vous voyez les connexions logique ils
sont là sans que je sois là le moins de
mathématiques il existe sans qu'on n'y
touche mais la compréhension de ce monde
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas du
tout abstrait c'est quelque chose de
concret de vécu et de ressenti c'est
quelque chose qui se crée dans mon corps
si je comprends c'est quelque chose qui
est dans mon corps pour que je comprenne
je dois réfléchir on ne peut pas me
faire réfléchir
il n'y a pas de meilleure façon de
comprendre si j'ai compris quelque chose
peu importe comment je vais compris les
mathématiques s'en fiche
comment j'ai réussi à comprendre quelque
chose c'est pour ça que les
mathématiques dont la possibilité ou
chemin personnel
même s'il porte en elle les vérités
universelles les mathématiques
m les gens différents juste parce que
les gens différents réfléchissent
différemment et donc qu'on prenne
différemment et donc réunis tous
ensemble qu'on prenne de la façon plus
profonde les mathématiques donc
fleurissent quand ils sont partagés
discuter et penser ensemble les
mathématiques fleurissent en communauté
ils ne sont pas faites pour classer ou
séparés en tout cas c'est ce que je vois
quand je fais des mathématiques quand je
plonge ma tête dedans dans ce monde
parallèle où il ya que des objets des
figures des structures des questions et
après il ya le vrai monde
l'école ou un c'est les maths aux
enfants et où la plupart des questions
commencent par combien et pas par
pourquoi les questions la réponse
qu'elle il faut trouver dans un temps
limité fixée pour tout le monde sans
aucune marge de manoeuvre
je suis chercheur en mathématiques
quelques chiffres vous cherchez comme si
les mathématiques ne consistaient que de
chiffres que de nombres que deux mesures
que de règles appliquées sans trop se
poser de questions comme si on enfonçait
des clous dans un mur à rythme régulier
je ne cherche pas de chiffres je cherche
des histoires notre classement en maths
va-t-il influencer nos choix de vie le
choix professionnels ceux de nos enfants
notre continent compétences en
mathématiques
vont-elles rester avec nous comme un
souvenir profond nous allons peut-être
le joindre à notre identité je suis nul
en maths je ne suis pas bon en maths
j'ai toujours eu de bonnes notes mais
nous allons vivre avec ces phrases je
suis nul en maths
cette fraise signori sud de l'île de
l'heureuse à prononcer et à entendre
sur quoi se base t elle sur un seul
nombre quelque chose sur 20 je pense
qu'il ya toujours une histoire derrière
un nombre je pense qu'il yad'autres
mathématiques ce sont les mathématiques
de l'autorité dans lesquelles quelqu'un
sais mieux comment je peux réfléchir il
quand c'est mieux comment quand et dans
quel ordre
je peux réfléchir ce sont les
mathématiques qui ne pardonne pas où
chaque faute est suivi par une punition
par une note ou parents regardent de
précision par une attitude envers
l'autre ce sont les mathématiques dans
lequel j'ai peur ce sont les
mathématiques dans lesquelles j'ai honte
ce sont les mathématiques que je n'ai
pas envie de faire mais c'est
mathématique elle existe et nous les
pratiquons tous
mes parents sont tous les deux
professeurs de mathématiques mes grands
parents on de côté dans ma maman ont
tous les deux fait les études de
mathématiques
j'ai commencé à faire des maths parce
que mes parents pensaient que ce serait
mieux pour moi et à 13 ans je me posais
pas trop de questions tout mal et bien
j'ai un trait dans une école spécialisée
en mathématiques
ça existe en russie et au début et le
long de mes études j'étais beaucoup
guidé par des bonnes notes
je pense que j'étais toujours curieuse
et j'ai toujours aimé apprendre mais
l'idée de la bonne note me faisait
battre le coeur de la façon quasi
obsessionnelle
heureusement j'ai eu de bons professeurs
qui m'ont appris par leur amour à leur
sujet et par leur attitude que une bonne
note ce n'est pas si important mais j'ai
longtemps de persister j'ai très têtu au
début je me suis dit à petit je me suis
rendu compte que c'était plus simple
pour moi de réussir les examens si je
comprenais vraiment ce qui se passe
mathématiquement le toque d'apprendre
bêtement parker donc toujours en
recherche de bonnes notes j'ai décidé
d'adapter ma stratégie de vraiment
comprendre les maths et donc c'est là
qu'ils m'ont attrapé c'est là que je
commençais à avoir du sens et à prendre
du plaisir à faire des mathématiques
je pense que comprendre a commencé à
être plus important que plaire je
continue à me battre contre les autres
mais thématiques tous les jours dans ma
tête je n'y arrive pas tous les jours
mais je fais de mon mieux je me dis que
je peux réfléchir calmement sur les
questions qui m'intéresse sans me
précipiter pour publier dans les
journaux internationaux les journaux
internationaux c'est un peu comme les
bonnes notes à l'école je me dis que je
peux poser des questions aussi mes nerfs
et aux conférences
même si j'ai très peur de paraître bête
je me dis que je peux faire des
mathématiques à ma façon
les mélanger avec le cinéma par exemple
parce que pourquoi pas les mathématiques
c'est un outil c'est tout
j'ai peur que nos confondues ont bien
trop souvent l'outil et l'utilisation
dont on fait de cet outil
le ti et la pratique mise en place de
cet outil que le rôle que les
mathématiques ont dans notre société et
leur place dans notre société ne
correspondent pas du tout à la vérité
des mathématiques et à la force qu'ils
ont à nous donner de l'assurance et de
l'espoir
nous avons pris des mauvaises habitudes
par rapport à mathématiques nous avons
pris les habitudes de les utiliser pour
se comparer les uns aux autres pour nous
d précis pour prendre du pouvoir
nous avons pris une habitude de enfoncé
les clous avec une océan infini ce que
je veux dire c'est que les mathématiques
c'est peut-être le mot mathématiques n'a
pas le même sens
quand nous disons que nous les aimons et
quand nous disons que nous ne les aimons
pas quand on fait des mathématiques
la première étape c'est de bien définir
de quoi on parle
c'est quoi pour vous les mathématiques
j'ai envie d'être clair que pour moi je
dis non aux règles prescrites dont je ne
comprends pas le sens je dis oui aux
lois universelles dont je peux saisir la
logique et le mystère à travers les
expériences et l'outil scientifique
je dis non à la compétition entre les
individus qui nous empêche à nous
respecter
je dis oui au partage autour des
questions qui nous sont intéressantes
je dis non à l'autorité je dis oui à la
beauté je dis oui avec ma tête je dis
oui
avec mon coeur je dis oui aux émotions
que les mathématiques peuvent nous
provoquer et pour être sincère ce n'est
pas toujours de la jao de
l'émerveillement
la plupart du temps ces rudes et dur
parce que nous sommes sur un bateau il
faut ramer pour pouvoir avancer parce
que oui les mathématiques sont
difficiles mais belle mais difficile
mais belle
mais difficile mais belle j'ai juste
envie de vous demander de savoir ce que
c'est pour vous les mathématiques et
soyez sûr à quoi ont dit non si vous
dites non aux mathématiques merci
[Applaudissements]